creo que ya tenemos las herramientas
espero para entender el concepto de lo
que es un sub espacio vectorial de rn
así que déjenme escribirlo aquí lo que
voy a enseñarte en este vídeo es que es
un sub espacio vectorial o sube espacio
a secas de hecho se utiliza mucho el sub
espacio solamente porque nosotros
sabemos que estamos hablando de álgebra
lineal y bueno para darte la definición
de este sub espacio de rn primero
déjenme tomarme un conjunto vemos un
subconjunto de rn y bueno este
subconjunto benz puede ser un
subconjunto de muchos elementos pero
cuando yo digo que es un subconjunto de
rn quiere decir que cada uno de los
vectores que forman este subconjunto
tiene n componentes porque recuerdan que
lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera
podemos decir que rn es igual a todos
los vectores de entradas de la forma x 1
x 2 x 3
así hasta x tienen todos estos tales
quien cada una de las componentes de
este efecto
o sea un número real es decir que x sea
un número en los reales para y entre 1 y
n es decir para todas las 6 para cada
una de las componentes y así podemos
visualizar a efe en un conjunto infinito
de vectores y fueron p es un subconjunto
de rn es decir que puede ser r n pero
puede ser que también sea solamente
algunos vectores de rn o inclusive
solamente un vector de rn pero ojo como
es un sub espacio y a su vez es un
subconjunto de rn lo que estoy diciendo
es que estamos hablando de un conjunto
que aunque puede ser rn puede ser que
también sea más pequeño que rn para que
no te confundas imagínate que aquí está
todo rn y bueno ven ve va a ser un
subconjunto de rn por lo tanto va a ser
un conjunto como éste que esté adentro
de rn puede ser rn pero que esté
compuesto de vectores con n componentes
y muy bien ya que tengo aquí a ver si yo
defino que b es un sub espacio de rn
y ahora sí ahí viene la definición de es
un sub espacio su espacio vectorial de
rn si cumple tres cosas la primera de
estas cosas es que el cero el vector
cero con n componentes debe de existir
en b b contiene al vector 0 al vector 0
y lo voy a poner así y recuerda que es
el vector donde todas sus componentes
son ceros es decir 0 0 0 0 todas estas y
tiene n componentes porque estamos en rn
ésta es un ave un poco más larga y bueno
el 0 debe de estar contenido en vez esa
es la primera la segunda es esta que si
x existe en b vamos a ponerlo aquí x
está en bien entonces para que sea un
sub espacio de rl tiene que pasar que si
nosotros tomamos un número ser un número
c en los reales esto es muy importante
no voy a tomar cualquier número en los
reales entonces la multiplicación de ese
por este vector x también tiene que
estar
y esto significa que se ha cerrado bajo
la multiplicación por escalar entonces
la segunda propiedad es que si x existen
ven entonces la multiplicación por un
escalar de este vector también tiene que
existir en b y bueno todo esto te había
contado que se le conoce como la
cerradura bajo la multiplicación la
cerradura bajo multiplicación escalar
entonces aquí está perfecto entonces mi
primera propiedad es que contenga el
cero mi segunda propiedad es que si x
existen b entonces se por equis existen
ven
imagínate que este es x que existen bien
entonces se x x también debe de existir
aquí en vez porque si se x x no me diera
a quien me me diera un [ __ ] que
estuviera afuera de mi subconjunto ven
entonces esto no sería un sub espacio
para que sea un sub espacio la
multiplicación por ser y se lo estamos
definiendo en los números reales es la
multiplicación por un escalar real debe
de caer también en este subconjunto y
bueno esto es que se cumple la propiedad
de la cerradura bajo la multiplicación
escalar ahora imagínate que tomo a otros
dos vectores este de aquí que se va a
llamar am y este de aquí que se va a
llamar ven y ambos viven en ven en mí
sub espacio ven entonces cyan y ven
viven en ven en vez de vaca este sub
espacio y que también es un subconjunto
de rn si ellos dos existen en ven
entonces la suma de ambos también tiene
que existir en b y esto quiere decir que
si nosotros tenemos dos vectores y la
suma está también en b significa que
tenemos la propiedad de la cerradura
bajo la suma ésta es la cerradura bajo
la suma de vectores esto quiere decir
que si nos tomamos dos vectores
cualesquiera aquí en ven entonces su
suma también debe de caer en b y
entonces al final puedo concluir que si
pasan estas tres propiedades que
acabamos de ver que por cierto estas
tres propiedades son importantísimas que
me contenga el cero que b sea cerrado
bajo la
multiplicación por escalar y que me
cumpla que sea cerrado bajo la suma
entonces se cumple que esto es un sub
espacio y de igual manera si nosotros
tenemos estas tres propiedades entonces
podemos decir que el subconjunto b es un
sub espacio de rn como es una definición
podemos también decir esto que el tener
estas tres propiedades implica que
tengamos un sub espacio de rn muy bien
bueno espero que quede mucho más claro a
qué me refiero cuando hablo de un sub
espacio pero si no vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos que sean un poco más concretos
acerca de la idea de que es un sub
espacio y no sea tan abstracto como esto
y bueno no sé si estos ejemplos tengan
ser un poco más concreto el asunto pero
pero al menos va a aterrizar un poco más
la idea imagínate que tengo el caso más
trivial tengo que ver es igual al
subconjunto de vectores que solamente
contiene el vector 0 es decir que b es
el conjunto de vectores que tiene al 0 y
vamos a pensar que estamos en r3 por lo
tanto tenemos un vector 0 con 3
componentes
000 acaso este subconjunto ve que
solamente contiene el 0 es un sub
espacio de r3 y esta es mi pregunta que
yo quiero responder si este es un
conjunto b como no estoy definiendo es
un sub espacio de r3 y si quiero saber
si es un suv espacio de 3 tiene que
cumplir tres condiciones la primera es
que el 0 esté en este sub espacio y si
te das cuenta el 0 está en este sub
espacio porque justo así lo construimos
entonces palomita muy bien mi segunda
propiedad es que se ha cerrado bajo la
multiplicación por escalar por una
escala real entonces vamos a tomarnos a
este vector 000 y vamos a multiplicarlo
por cualquier constante y vamos a ver
que obtenemos si lo que obtenemos está
dentro debe pues ya lo hicimos vamos a
ver si cumple la segunda propiedad
entonces vamos a multiplicar por la
constante y me dan c por 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
y 0 existen b por lo tanto estamos
diciendo que si hablamos de la
multiplicación por escalar entonces de
cerrado es decir que bs
bajo la multiplicación por escalar muy
bien ya tengo mi segunda propiedad y
ahora vamos a fijarnos en mi tercera
propiedad si nosotros tomamos un vector
que solamente está el vector cero en vez
y lo multiplicamos por cualquier
constante entonces nos da otro vector o
en este caso el mismo que también está
en b por lo tanto palomita y ahora vamos
a probar la última propiedad que dice
que si tomamos dos vectores en b vamos a
ver si la suma de estos dos vectores
también existen bien pero el vector cero
más el vector cero me da el vector cero
por lo tanto podemos decir que b también
ha cerrado bajo la suma aunque aquí
solamente tengamos un vector si tomamos
a ese vector y lo sumamos consigo mismo
vamos a obtener un vector que también
está en vez y bueno tal vez este caso
sea muy trivial pero al menos ya
acabamos de probar que ve en el caso en
el que sea solamente el vector 0 es un
sub espacio de r3 muy bien ahora vamos a
ver otros ejemplos un poco más difíciles
y tal vez no tan intuitivo acerca de qué
es un sub espacio acerca de un conjunto
que no sea un sub espacio
después de r3 o de r2 y para eso voy a
trabajar precisamente con estos planos
que ya tengo aquí dibujados así que
vamos a tomarnos un subconjunto y no
forzosamente por eso un sub espacio que
voy a llamar ese ese va a ser mi
subconjunto de los vectores en r2 de la
forma x 1 x 2 x 1 x 2 y bueno recuerda
que estos son elementos de r 2 porque
tenemos aquí un plano cartesiano tales
que tales que se cumpla la siguiente
condición tal vez que x 1 sea mayor o
igual que cero es decir x 1 sea positivo
o 0 esta es la condición para x 1
mientras que x 2 no tiene condiciones no
tiene restricciones puede tomar
cualquier valor y si te das cuenta
estamos hablando de vectores en este
plano cartesiano que esté en el primero
en el segundo cuadrante que estén arriba
o abajo de esta línea porque como x1 es
positivo o 0 entonces puede ser a partir
de aquí y bueno x2 no tienen las
elecciones por lo tanto x
para arriba o abajo de esta línea verde
es decir como x2 no tiene restricciones
lo voy a tratar de dibujar por aquí
puede valer todo esto cualquier número
negativo puede valer 0 o cualquier
número positivo y entonces si te das
cuenta en dónde está la intersección de
estas dos condiciones es el primer
cuadrante recordando los cuadrantes y el
cuarto cuadrante el primer y el cuarto
cuadrante y bueno ahora la pregunta es
acaso será ese un sub espacio de r2 es
lo que nosotros queremos hablar de sus
espacios entonces para probar que ese es
un sub espacio lo primero que hay que
hacer explicarnos en las tres
propiedades la primera propiedad decía
que si con teníamos al 0 0 y bueno si
cuando tenemos al 0 0 porque como x 1
puede ser mayor o igual a 0 pues
entonces pueden ser 0 y x2 no tiene
restricción por lo tanto pues puede ser
cero entonces el 0 0 está contenido en
ese el caso cuando x 1 es 0 y x2 también
lo es y ya tenemos la primera propiedad
por tanto palomita
vamos a probar otra de las propiedades y
se me ocurre probar la propiedad de la
suma si yo me tomo dos vectores aquí la
suma estará dentro siempre de este
subconjunto pues vamos a ver imagínate
que yo me tomo este vector de aquí me
tomo este otro vector de aquí y date
cuenta que la suma perfecto sí que haya
dentro de este subconjunto y si yo me
tomo otro por acá y otro vector por acá
date cuenta que la suma parece ser que
siempre que hay dentro de este mismo
subconjunto pero esta no es una
demostración matemática rigurosa será
cierto siempre pues vamos a ver
supongamos que yo me tomo dos vectores
no voy a tomar el vector
avn y por otra parte me voy a tomar el
vector cedem cdl y sigue lo sumo que me
va a quedar estos dos bueno me va a
quedar a más y más demás del estero nada
más ve más de y si te das cuenta lo de
abajo no importa lo que importa es lo de
arriba y lo de arriba siempre es mayor o
igual a cero a es mayor o igual que cero
porque justo así está definido en su
conjunto se es mayor o igual que cero y
por lo tanto la suma de dos cosas que
son mayores
igual es que me da algo mayor o igual
que 0 y bueno como abajo no tengo
restricciones entonces mis resultados si
es parte de este subconjunto entonces la
suma también funciona y cuando se cumple
la propiedad de la suma le habíamos
puesto el nombre rimbombante de que se
cumple la cerradura bajo la suma en este
conjunto es cerrado bajo la suma ahora
vamos a ver si se cumple también la
propiedad de la multiplicación por una
escalera así que déjame tomarme un
vector
a ver si este vector que este es nuestro
subconjunto lo multiplicamos por un
escalar pero como puede ser cualquier
escalar me voy a tomar una escalera
especial me voy a tomar al menos uno y
si lo multiplicamos por menos uno me
queda menos a menos b y bueno de una
manera gráfica
imagínate que me tomo el vector 24 aquí
está el vector 24 y entonces si yo lo
multiplicó por menos uno me va a quedar
el vector menos 2 menos 4 es decir este
vector de kim y claramente de una manera
muy visual se ve que no cae este vector
adentro de nuestro subconjunto que
queremos y bueno es que tiene toda la
lógica
porque si nosotros tenemos a este vector
avn entonces si a es distinto de 0 menos
a va a ser un número negativo cuando yo
me tomo un número positivo y lo
multiplicó por menos uno o por cualquier
número negativo entonces me da de
resultado un número negativo en este
caso b no tiene ningún problema porque b
no tiene restricciones sin embargo el
problema es la componente de arriba y la
componente de arriba cambia de ser
positiva a negativa y un número negativo
no es mayor que 0 y por lo tanto no está
en un subconjunto s es decir que nuestro
resultado de multiplicar a un vector
cuya primera componente sea un número
positivo por un escalar negativo no
podría obtener algo que esté ni
subconjunto y si no voy a obtener algo
que éste no es un conjunto puede decir
que este subconjunto no es cerrado bajo
la multiplicación por escalar y que
cerca estuvimos cumplíamos dos de las
propiedades cumplimos que con teníamos
al cero y que este subconjunto era
cerrado bajo la suma sin embargo no se
cumplió la tercera propiedad y por lo
tanto este subconjunto ese no es un sub
espacio
r2 bueno a superar este final trágico y
vámonos a ser mejor otro ejercicio
porque además yo tengo una duda muy
importante imagínate que yo me tomo un
conjunto de vectores y me tomo el
espacio vectorial de un conjunto de
vectores este espacio vectorial generado
por este conjunto de vectores es un sub
espacio de r2 así que imagínate que me
tomo estos tres vectores y su espacio
vectorial generado por ellos tres será
esto un sub espacio válido de r 2 esta
es mi pregunta y bueno me estoy tomando
tres vectores aleatorios
es decir que me podría tomar cualquier
cantidad de vectores y en cualquier r n
entonces fíjate bien si yo me tomo
cualquier cantidad de vectores y me tomo
el espacio vectorial generado por esta
cantidad de vectores en este caso estos
tres y a esto lo llamo un será y un sub
espacio válido de rn pues vamos a
probarlo lo primero que quiero ver es si
está el cero aquí es decir si contiene
el cero y bueno eso es muy fácil de
verlo dar respuestas que sí porque si yo
multiplico 0 veces
de 10 veces de 20 veces de 30 veces por
el vector de 10 veces por el vector de
20 veces por el vector de 3 pues esto me
va a dar el vector 0 y por lo tanto el 0
está incluido en el espacio vectorial
generado por esos tres vectores porque
el campo se encuentra una combinación
lineal de estos tres vectores que me da
el vector cero por lo tanto este sí está
ahora vamos a probar la cerradura bajo
multiplicación por escalar entonces lo
primero que voy a hacer es tomarme una
combinación lineal de estos tres
vectores y la voy a llamar x es decir
que x va a ser igual a no sé si me
ocurre ponerles constante cc1 x b1 c2
por b 2 + c3 por b 3 + c3 por b 3 es
decir una combinación lineal de sus tres
vectores que por cierto por definición
sabemos que está en el espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores y bueno
qué pasa si yo me tomo una constante cm
y la multiplicó por x 'star hace por
equis
dentro de este espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores y bueno
no espera en lugar de ponerse por equis
para no confundirnos voy a poner otra
constante la constante a por el vector x
y bueno multiplicando del lado derecho
me queda hace 1 por de uno más hace 2
por de 2 más a porsche 3 por b 3 y bueno
si te das cuenta
esta es una combinación lineal de los
vectores b1 b2 y b3
si yo nombro aa por c 1 una constante aa
por c 2 otra constante y para finalizar
aa porsche 3 a otra constante entonces
obtengo una combinación lineal de b1 b2
y b3 esto es lo mismo que ese 4 por b
165 por b 2 más de 6 por b 3 estas son
constantes las cuales están en los
números reales por lo tanto me estoy
encontrando con una combinación lineal
de b1 b2 y b3 y si es una combinación
lineal está en el espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores y
entonces acá puedo enseñarte que cuando
yo multiplico por una escalar
también está en el espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores es
decir que existen en un y por lo tanto
puedo concluir que este conjunto 1 es
cerrado bajo la multiplicación por
escalar muy bien ya tengo dos
propiedades ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
con la propiedad de la suma si yo me
tomo esta x que por cierto es una
combinación lineal de estos tres
vectores y ahora me voy a tomar otra
vectores no voy a tomar una conexión
lineal llamada james lleva a ser igual a
no se lo voy a tomar de 1 por b 1 más de
2 por b 2 más de 3 por b 3 y bueno aquí
tengo otra combinación lineal de estos
tres vectores ahora qué pasa si yo sumo
x + james x + james es la suma de dos
vectores que están en este subconjunto y
bueno x mayer date cuenta que me va a
quedar de resultado hace uno más de uno
por de uno lo puedo factorizar el b 10
más de uno por uno utilizando la
propiedad distributiva de los vectores
vamos a apuntar lo segundo más de uno
por b 1 ya esto le voy a sumar dos más
de 2 todo esto por b 2 ya esto le puedo
sumar de 3 más de 3 todo esto
multiplicado por b 3 es decir que sería
factor hizo b1 b2 y b3 me estoy
encontrando con una combinación lineal
de b1 b2 y b3 porque date cuenta que ese
1 más de 1 es una constante de 2 más de
2 es otra constante y c3 más de 3 es
otra constante por lo tanto aquí tengo
otra combinación lineal de b1 b2 y b3 y
eso quiere decir que la suma también cae
en el espacio vectorial generado por
estos tres vectores y por lo tanto estoy
demostrando que este conjunto es cerrado
bajo la suma y entonces se cumplen las
tres propiedades ya tengo que el cero
existe en un que es cerrado bajo la
multiplicación y bajo la suma por lo
tanto es un espacio válido de rn y eso
es cierto
seguramente me vas a decir oye sal si yo
me tomo un espacio vectorial generado
por solamente un vector
supongamos no sé el 11 a poco esto es un
sub espacio mal ido tr2 pues vamos a
probarlo lo primero que voy a hacer es
verlo de una manera gráfica si aquí
tengo mi vector 11 entonces todo el
espacio vectorial generado por este
vector 1-1 es todas las combinaciones
lineales de este vector 11 pero como
solamente tenemos un vector es
multiplicar a este vector por cualquier
constante por lo tanto nos va a quedar
cualquiera de estos vectores cualquiera
de estos otros vectores y en fin si yo
me tomo o me fijo en el espacio
vectorial generado por este vector 1-1
esencialmente me estoy refiriendo a una
línea recta a esta línea recta que estoy
trazando justo
muy bien y entonces mi primera pregunta
es si yo quisiera saber que esta línea
recta es un sub espacio de r2 lo primero
que tendría que mostrar es que el cero
estuviera aquí entonces vamos a
multiplicar el 0 por el vector 11 y esto
me dan pues 000 por 100 por 10 y
entonces me estoy tomando la
multiplicación de este vector 11 por el
escalar 0 yo obtengo el vector 0 0 que
está en r 2 por lo tanto ya cumplimos la
primera propiedad
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa con la multiplicación por un
escalar si yo me tomo el escalar cm y lo
multiplicó por 11 pues esto
esencialmente es la definición del
espacio vectorial generado por mi vector
11 si te das cuenta justo así fue como
construye esta línea recta multiplicando
el vector 11 por todas las constantes
que a mí se me ocurrieron y entonces
esta constante también va a ser que
cumpla mi propiedad de la multiplicación
por escalar ahora imagínate que yo me
tomo un vector am que por cierto lo
podemos ver como se uno por el vector 11
y este vector le voy a sumar un vector
vemos que también lo podemos ver como el
vector
2 que multiplica el vector 11 porque
tanto a como ven están en el espacio
vectorial generado por el 11 bueno si yo
somos todos voy a obtener el resultado
el 11 que multiplica es más déjame
ponerlo mejor así con un poco más de
espacio c1 c2 que va a multiplicar al
vector 11 y bueno al final estoy
obteniendo una tercera constante c1 c2
que multiplica el vector 11 pero que
también está en el espacio vectorial
generado por el vector 11 porque estamos
hablando de una constante si lo
quisiéramos ver esto de una manera
gráfica
imagínate que esta es una nueva
constante y entonces imagínate que yo
meto un cierto vector por aquí este de
aquí y después le quiero sumar este
nuevo vector me voy a agarrar otro
vector con otro color y le quiero sumar
este vector de aquí si te das cuenta
cuando sumamos estos dos vectores y
juntamos cabeza con cola entonces vamos
a obtener este vector de verde déjenme
cambiar de color a un color más
llamativo este vector que estoy
obteniendo aquí es decir al final me
mantengo en esta línea recta y si me
mantengo en esta línea recta entonces
también se cumple
propiedad de la suma y por lo tanto este
conjunto que es el espacio vectorial
generado por el vector 11 es cerrado
bajo la multiplicación por escalares
cerrado bajo la suma y entonces es un
sub espacio de r2 y bueno justo esto es
lo que hablábamos aquí arriba que si yo
me tomo el espacio vectorial generado
por n vectores en rn este conjunto que
forma el espacio vectorial generado por
estos n vectores siempre va a ser un sub
espacio de rm y bueno aquí está todo
sobre sub espacios nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo